en danger chantal sur la tête de ma mère
quand je te vois chez toi avec le buffet
derrière j'ai l'impression qu'on m'a
muté sur affaire conclue sans rigoler on
dirait que tu vas de quoi ils le font à
distance est plus là moi ce que je
propose d'ailleurs
c est ce que vous pouvez est-ce qu'on
est ce qu'on va moi je dis on fait une
vente aux enchères en direct on achète
des trucs que vous avez de chez vous
vous amener un truc
voilà que vous voulez vendre aux
enchères et on donne tout ce qu'on a
acheté pour les hôpitaux de paris je
fais des enchères je vous dis voilà on
fait monter les enchères entre nous
chacun sait où ça te va sachant talent
bien ça te plait ça allait allez-y vous
pouvez aller aller chercher ce que vous
voulez tout le monde est à quoi bouder
tubes du dieu du g11 chapeau de seine
vas-y tu laves à divonne chercher la
laisser rentrer chez moi j'ai un à temps
plein doute
attends bouge pas dit chantal way aller
chercher tous envie de regarder gaël
berger s'est pleinement votre costume de
san bande dans c'est quoi cette gamine à
temps partiel alors attendre
chantal chacun va faire 1 va sortir un
objet pour les hôpitaux de paris
d'accord on va leur monter les enchères
ok alors on commence par les lits elie
qu'est ce que tu veux mon chéri alors
attendons maintenant l'arrivée on attend
le retour de philippe lellouche et dolly
chez vous vous allez voir et on peut
même et après on les offrira à des
téléspectateurs sous les sièges parce
qu'il est vrai qu'il faut être comme des
oufs 1 franchement c'est génial ça c'est
la chienlit
ces affaires qu'on plus à faire conclut
ses affaires conclues à la tunisienne
allez on démarre par couderc est ce que
tu vas en bout des repas du bout du bout
des seins oui alors vas-y qu'est ce que
tu nous vends je suis entre h à poway à
chapeau que je mets souvent
ouais les chapeaux taille 54 donc pour
petit est un jeu complet avec lequel
j'ai fait des émissions dont tpm plein
avaient tous il est très propre
j'ai combattu la paye est celui-là moi
tu la payes tu te rappelles ou pas ça tu
l'as tu acceptes tu la taxe à kamel
tulle avola jamel est ce que je vous dis
je vous existe quelque chose
généralement quand il a des affaires on
des vêtements chez lui où les âmes
et oui les a bola jamel donc voilà les
attaques ces webcams à leur endroit
donc ça sensu sûr et certain tom c'est
pas à moi je suis enceinte axa djamel
vous parle ici à jamel je te connais je
connais trop j'étais sur tulle avait
taxé adjabel voilà voilà alors un 1 sur
3 aux puces ayant appartenu à jamel
debbouze qui a été capté par van der
annoncé tram est vraiment celui qui
appartenaient déjà mais attends bouge
pas badie a dit hé quoi il ya donné
celui qui appartenait à dia mais voilà
on va voir combien pour le chapeau de
bouder vous mettez combien on démarre à
5,05 euros 6 euros pour chantal qu'ils
auront 6 euros chantal à l'été ils ont
comme est moins on peut mettre - le
dernier qui a parlé
voilà bah ouais si je roule pour chantal
6 euros non alors 15 euros 15 euros et
10 à 20 20 euros pour l'achat solidaire
24 ans marc-antoine compte 40 pourrait
les rendre un désert en plus aller 5-0
s'accentuait philippe lellouche pour le
chapeau de bouder entre 60 soit ce site
électronique vous voudriez pas non plus
les mecs soient sincères dit chantal à
16 ans braga s'emballe j'emballe
s'emballe au lit mais sans balle pour le
chapeau ayant appartenu à jamel et à
bouder s'emballe aller s'emballe s'en va
et c'est vous et lamballe vous êtes plus
que moi fait foi légendaire et danser
pour toi aussi tu repars avec le chapeau
pour samba l'aller ça fait 100 euros
pour les hôpitaux de paris en plus à
l'est elie qu'est ce que tu vois les
qu'est ce que tu vois c'est un prix que
j'ai reçus en fait dans un festival dans
le sud de l'aisne petit bonbon sa boîte
pour 2012 c'était pour lui un prix pour
les petites annonces pas mal c'est dû
faire marla c'est un beau cadeau à ça
c'est un beau cadeau
sa mise après toujours est-ce que mise à
prix 10 euros 10 euros
allez on démarre à 10 on all i way a
marqué lycée monte dessus je suis prêt
si jamais le savoir sur l'ange bleu oui
marc elie semoun oui a marqué un essai
pour 50 euros
et les téléspectateurs hashtag affaires
conclues du tunisien et vous repartez
avec le cadeau vous serez tirés au sort
sur twitter déjà cherché alors ses
voûtes dessus ouais y'a combien d'offres
80 euros à 80 euros au bout de quatre
heures régulières et 90e chantal ladesou
pour la statuette d'elie semoun le prix
90 90 une fois 90 2 x 90 3 fois c'est
pour toi chantal à l'aise
ok la chanteuse chantal chantal question
alors moi je pensais de cette île est là
que j'ai porté gens c'est quoi cette
mamie qui est une veste orange et
valence les bagages de livrer ce que
j'avais dit que j'avais des costumes
assez extravagant et elle l hébreu des
moulins on a un beau produit
voilà ça fait un beau cadeau blessures
sur quelque chose de rare oui c'est
assez particulier car il ya son talent
c'est une 3d mais c'est quoi la matière
chantal net c'est une jolie coton c'est
un concours on est tous merci risée
mercure visuel c'est un petit peu
folklorique mais c'est très joli vers
cerise et le coton c'est un coton avec
des vélos des 7600 des marais on démarre
à 40 euros là dessus c'est du moins
c'est bien lieu alors ce jour non 60 60
soit ce qu'on évite faire la pré
orientale et en plus c'est quoi la
taille ya pas de taille tu sais sans
bouder t'inquiète pas toi ça te ferait
une robe quoi qu'il arrive ce sera très
beau tag est pas inquiète pas toi tu
seras tu seras highlander toi avec
t'inquiète pas faire s'inquiète pas tu
te rends matrix ou condate combien 80 81
cents à 100 sans s'emballe s'emballe une
fois s'emballe 2 x 123 x c'est pour toi
et tu repars avec la cebo big flo et oli
mon chéri c'est quoi ton cadeau c'est
quoi ton truc
alors a dit philippe philippe tu as quoi
ce truc j'ai acheté au japon quand on a
fait le road trip de top gear au japon
voilà c'est beau ça la vraie chemise
hawaïenne d'époque étoiles effet
l'arrivée personnage en question quelle
taille en c2 chez attends je vais te le
dire xl quelle taille est alors bon cela
fait une couette avec booder a tout fait
quoi avec booder maintenance et tu sais
c'est la vraie chemise hawaïenne
fabriquée au japon mais avec les
tisseuses américaine tu sais parce que
maintenant les japonais ils ont racheté
tous le fabriquer les ricains ils sont
pas rancuniers
alors non pas dix balles 10 balles mise
à prix avait pas mal elle est belle et
révèle la belle eva caraman balles
directes à les magnifiques au lit et
chaussures 28 euros pour celle là 50
euros pour une couette ça ferait une
couette à bouder il a dit elie 6 à
l'odeur des 655 euros avec l'odeur de
philippe lellouche bout des 55 65 65
celanese 70 chantal 80 81 kg 81 81 j'ai
déjà de 90 projets 90 au lit on peut
aller jusqu'à 100 comme ça on arrondit
sens j'aurais depuis longtemps et je me
sens pour chantal ladesou qui part avec
la chemise hawaïenne chez pascal maurer
chantal mais c'est pour elle aussi
attend ses chantages cela me dis moi
chantal a été dit ici pour participer à
une émission vous faire des courses
non mais c'est total honda on l'a on a
des oignons des aubergines qu'arriva on
a plein de marc-antoine que du vent
basile boli alors normalement je vais
mettre des places de spectacle mais je
peux mettre un objet pas de problème
vas-y non mais vas-y fais ce que tu veux
mon chéri deux places de spectacle avec
un accès en loge fort après le spectacle
elle aurait dû fournir note aussi avec 2
ce sera en 2030 ce serait en 2030 le
spectacle allez on est aussi une
dédicace que c'est quoi s à marc antoine
va mettre à la pige le jeu l'offre tout
de suite aux téléspectateurs franchement
on les offre avec la production parce
que ça c'est un très beau casting c'est
un très beau cadeau liste des cadeaux de
merde cyril mais aussi celle là la c log
c'est l'homme qui il donne de sa
personne mais non c'est pas moi il à
faire
un spectacle love des places de
spectacle est ce que j'essaie de faire
un objet en plus tu es mieux aussi là
alors c'est un radio réveil c'est pas un
truc de mervent mais quand même pas si
si je lis des bases des trucs il fait du
bien c'est ça ouais non je m'en sers
encore ça a été l'enfer radio et toi
jean grenier lui l'hyper scott skiles
qui va jeter sa ki ve ca sion veut dire
ne va pas l'instaurer marc-antoine
regarde les mercredis regardez pas de
spectacle au nom chantôme blessé
non mais on va lui donner chantal je te
l'offre de l'offre a dit van cachée de
bagdad alors j'ai commencé au lit que tu
fais moi très rouge et un bon truc j'ai
un bon truc c'est j'avais volts et je
vous le dit j'avais volé un boillat
quand j'ai fait envoyer un nom fort ah
ouais pas mal j'ai volé en maths un
boyau jeu laissez moi une étagère avec
moi tu vois tu me connais sucre est
obligé j'aime bien les petits trucs
comme ça chez moi
alain bouillard a tout autant tu as volé
aboya qui appelle tout de suite la
police appelle tout de suite le csa je
n'ai rien à faire
question oui alors au lieu alors est un
brouillard c'est pas mal je mets biz a
pris 20 bal va mal non non c'était pas
que verbale ses collègues d'or pierre
attendez vous non mes frères on ne va
pas mettre de 2000 boul danton boyard à
jules vous pouvez très bien
tu crois quoi parce que j'ai volé entre
deux modes demain dans la bresse ain
luna est accusé de recel
non mr abbas ont fait des trucs volume
bougeait pas et les gars y aperçoit ya
le père quoique me parler et
marc-antoine ramène le brouillard et au
lit je te l'achète a pas mal fait mon
frérot bah moi je lui achète un mal
merci aux nombreux contrats en cours et
les salaires ou la chine recèle bon
choix sont ouvertes et je peux pas
personne n'a dit elie elissa te plaît
pas ça j'essaie de bien manger en fait
ça a été volé c'était c'était pour une
association donc sans fond si vous êtes
avec pdg de la langue à boire que holly
a volé aboya et c'est vrai qu'est nichée
là que je le vois ici dix pensent à
l'association saint pierre qui avait un
brouillard en moi quand ils ont pesé
débrouillard et on sait que ses pouvoirs
non c'est que c'est quoi je les écoutais
je me l'expliquer ce que je peux
m'expliquer on m'a dit ça on avait on
avait fait pour le secours pop et où on
avait beau défi on avait rajouté de
l'argent de notre poche et à la fin
quand c'était fini à quand l'émission
est terminée j'ai pris un petit voyage
tu vois un screen comme ça pour la voir
en souvenir tout simplement
bah ça va ça va aller ça passe ça parce
que tu lises était la phrase on le on le
pardonne on le pardonne